things that i could check in on i don't
know but i would love to have you on the
podcast were you neurotic on the set of
undateable
i heard some things but you were just on
oh really what did you hear
that you were in the beginning of your
first show and there was a little neuro
neurosis going on on the show i
definitely my first season in particular
yes i came into some really strong
self-awareness when i turned
like 32. okay so the first little bit of
undateable
it was uh i'm sure you heard some things
that i maybe don't even know and
probably
no it wasn't anything bad it was just
that
i just found i had heard rumors like
what did you hear
just that you were like neurotic on set
and that you would like you know
um what funnier lines or i don't know
what it might be
yeah probably i probably wanted funnier
or more lines
but it was it got to the point that
where i would hear it from the
rumor mill that you were outwardly from
the people on the cast who are friends
other people let's just say that i don't
know man but you know what i'll tell you
this much
i am not who i was before but i am proud
of him and i have
learned from him and uh dude that's the
best
about make me cry that's the best answer
i've ever heard
because whatever you are and i'm trying
to figure that out right now my friend
yeah you should be proud of whatever you
are i really like you i really like you
too
i think you're a beautiful being i do i
do you know there aren't a lot of people
that i
um naturally no my eyes are watering
i felt like you'd like me and that was
okay but i didn't
i wanted you to wow you're an agent of
chaos
in like there are certain people that i
feel very like
con just like a magnet to him being one
of them
and i just get him whatever chaos
whatever agent of chaos this is
i get i love i adore all parts of it
right i feel the same way about you and
i just met you thank you and i didn't
think i would
i thought this would be a dreadful
podcast and i really really really like
you
oh is that why you came in like uh i
guess we've already got a shield on my
face
she came in i've never seen her wear
shield before first first time a shield
on this podcast what did i say about him
before
be careful with him he might be a vector
yeah that's exactly what i said that's
the opposition you're the opposite a
vector
for just germs and bacteria i didn't
know that you were careful i didn't
think you would bring your own mic
i didn't know that you'd bring your own
headphones i'm actually like so
impressed
my podcast is is literally called take
your shoes off i thought that was just
an asian an homage to
the asian folks like us because we take
our shoes off yeah
no it's it's uh take your shoes off is
the easiest one for like when you come
into my house there are so many rules
that i feel like taking shoes off is the
dipping their toe in
like oh i get it he's somebody who wants
things a certain way and then
you got to wash your hands you got to
change your shirt shorts you know all
these things so it's just like the
easiest one
so yeah i'm a clean person and all right
so we just did an extra 20 minutes